hello everyone and welcome to a game
that just finished from round two of
this year's Tata steel chess tournament
it is ala fua versus param makulu ala
coming off from a win against Yan pest
in round one and the maulu um his game
against Pand in round one ended in a
draw uh this game is it's really nice
but it's also a really weird one 18
moves of known Theory and then as usual
things uh things take a wrong turn so
let's check it out alza has the white
pieces here and he opened with E4 with
have Pawn to E5 Knight F3 Knight to C6
and Bishop to B5 the Lopez is on the
board uh Knight F6 and now just castles
offering D4 Pawn which param grabs this
is the Rio Gambit accepted Rook to E1
attacking the Knight and Knight to D6
now attacking the bishop here so Knight
captures an E5 threatening some very
nasty discoveries here so you have to
block The Rook Bishop to E7 and now
Bishop back to F1 again nothing new here
Al play before Knight captures Rook
captures cast and now Pawn to D4 Chasing
The Rook away with Bishop to F6 Rook to
E1 and now Rook to E8 uh Bishop to F4
you could play some other moves I think
Pawn to C3 and Bishop to F4 are the two
to two main Wes also maybe Knight to C3
uh but here just Rook captures on E1
Queen captures and now Knight to E8 you
could also go after the D4 Pawn but it's
uh well it's very dangerous your knight
is on D6 uh White might even capture it
to mess up your Pawn structure and okay
up a pawn but black will have these
doubled pawns here and maybe even
something like Knight to C3 it's a
pretty uh bad uh you know option to to
go for also Bishop to D3 Queen to E4
black might have troubles defending the
the king also the queen side pawns might
become a little bit weak so nothing to
look forward to so instead Knight to E8
was played now you were ready to March
forward with that D Pawn Knight to C3
and now a param does go for the D4 pawn
bishop captures on D4 and now Knight
Knight to D5 putting pressure on C7 but
okay for the moment it is defended by
the Knight we have Pawn to D6 and now
Bishop to G5 attacking the queen here
and the problem is if you just go Bishop
to F6 to trade everything you can't
trade the way you really want to because
after Knight captures with check Knight
captures and Bishop captures you have to
mess up your Pawn structure if you
capture with the queen then the White
Queen delivers Checkmate on E8 so you're
going to have to play like this and
white will always have a small Edge
whether it's enough to win it's hard to
say but it's going to be annoying for a
very long time to say the least so
instead after this bishop to G5 move bam
blocks with Pawn to F6 and now Bishop to
H4 uh Bishop captures on B2 grabbing yet
another Pawn Rook to B1 and Bishop back
to E5 and now it's all known up to up to
this point there are like 20 games from
from really strong players with this
exact same line Pawn to F4 and this is
where param probably mixed stop his
lines because the way this is usually
played uh is by attacking the Knight
with C6 and now after F captures on E5 C
captures on D5 e captures on F6 Knight
Will capture not something like Bishop
to D3 and the game continues yes black
is up two pawns but those are it's a
double D pawn and nothing spectacular
white does have the bishop pair the I
semi open file for the white Rook if
anyone it's it's even white who's better
here maybe you know a slight Advantage
but um uh the you know the pawn the two-
Pawn material difference doesn't really
matter but after F4 it seems that Parham
remembered that the Knight should be def
attacked but he didn't do it with the c
Pawn he actually played Bishop to E6 and
this is now a problem uh and of course
it is now as of move 18 that we have a
completely new game because Ala plays
Bishop to C4 and now the problem is uh
you can't just leave your Bishop here
because uh if you ever capture on D5
also Bishop captures on D5 will come
with check so that's a problem also
there are ideas like Knight captures on
F6 with check followed by Bishop
captures on E6 with check so what can
you do here well param does continue in
the best possible way Bishop to D4 check
the move was also available on the
previous move it just doesn't um do all
that much C6 was definitely the way to
go uh King to H1 and now he brings the
bishop back Bishop to F7 and it seems
like there's no way for ala to actually
push for anything here uh except one and
ala f it Queen to
E4 okay what's next the bishop is
hanging we have Bishop back to C5 and
now Knight to E7 with check now the
point is King cannot go to h8 as the
bishop on F7 would hang so the King has
to come to f8 and now the H7 Pawn hangs
so Queen captures on H7 which means that
this bishop on C4 is sacrificed param
captures it and now comes the well the
move that param probably missed when he
played that P the C6 move if you saw it
you know probably wouldn't wouldn't have
been played feel free to pause the video
and try to find the absolute strongest
move for ala and the only winning one
while I give you a couple of
seconds so uh for those of you who were
able to do it congratulations on finding
this very nice maneuver and for those of
you who just want to enjoy the show it
is Rook the E1 Knight to G6 is also
strong but Rook to E1 just uh ends the
game pretty much on the spot not on the
spot by on the spot I mean if you know
with proper defense black can still
survive for like 4050 moves uh but uh
you
know you know even even your uncle sees
that black is only surviving here so
here you have to give up the queen
otherwise Queen T8 check Bishop goes
back and queen captures will be
Checkmate so the queen capturing on E7
is a must so Queen captures on E7 uh
Rook captures and now King captures on
E7 there was um a pause here I was
watching the game live and param took a
pause here he wanted to decide whether
to capture The Rook right away the
problem is uh if you just take the Rook
okay it seems like you have all this
material for the queen you would have a
knight bishop and Rook for a queen the
problem is if you capture then comes
Queen to E4 check and you also lose the
bishop on C4 but if you play Bishop to
G8 to attack the queen we can even show
it then Queen to h8 and again if you
take the Rook then Queen captures on G8
and um it's not much I mean the the
Knight still cannot move the Rook here
would is stuck on A8 it's a it's a
really bad position for black and also
you know that G4 G5 is coming uh White
is completely winning here uh so for
that reason param played King captures
on E7 and now comes Queen to E4 check
picking up the bishop this way well not
on C4 Bishop to E6 was played but now
Pawn to F5 uh also one of the reasons
why Pawn to F4 is such a strong move as
it completely avoids this line uh Rook
to d8 param trying to activate his
pieces but ala just launes forward with
Pawn to G4 and now Pawn to C6 still uh
maybe it's possible to survive a little
bit better with something like Pawn to
D5 giving up the bishop right away let's
say king f8 and now after Bishop to G3
putting pressure on this diagonal and
the C7 Pawn so the Knight can't really
move uh it's um you know it's it's a
tough position but not much to do for
black like Pawn to D4 King will come to
G2 and now you start pushing H4 you're
going to push the G Pawn the H Pawn uh
all in all you will at some point
Advance the pawn to G5 capture here
black will probably have to capture with
the G pawn and then the past H Pawn will
decide the game uh but param went Pawn
to C6 first and now ales just goes Pawn
to G5 we have King to f8 uh now comes F
captures on E sorry not g captures on F6
F captures on E6 you have to capture the
Bishop as the king unpinned here so uh
capture is now threatening E7 with check
and now param just brings the king back
to sort of block the pawn and maybe
activate his pieces a little bit uh but
G captures on F6 with check and now G
captures was played if Knight captures
it's again bad just Queen to G4 the
Knight of course is pinned uh you're
going after the pawn and if Rook to G8
Queen to G6 uh that's all there is so
instead after G captures on F6 G
captures on F6 was played but again
Queen to G four just incredibly strong
we have Pawn to D5 uh Queen to G8 now
defending and also preparing Queen to F7
but this is one of the most interesting
parts of the game uh it's never really a
good idea to play Queen to F7 otherwise
um uh parham's pieces will get developed
as long as you wait with this queen to
F7 move uh the Knight and Rook really
have no way into game so Bishop to D4
was played now Bishop to G3 and Bishop
to E5 offering a trade of Bishops which
ala goes for it sort of gives param a
strong Center H but it doesn't matter as
now it's time for a good friend the H
Pawn to start marching forward so Pawn
to H4 Pawn to E4 and now Pawn to H5 and
this is what I meant uh you have to keep
the queen on G8 if you play something
like Queen to G5 all of a sudden Knight
to F6 and the Knight is activated the
king is activated The Rook can be
activated if you give a check then just
King captures pawn and the pawns are
Marching forward it will be param who
will have a pass Pawn very soon uh so
instead alza just keeps pushing Pawn to
H5 and now Pawn to D4 and um uh
similarly if let's say Knight to D6 plat
to try and activate pieces real quickly
then Queen to G5 check is super annoying
uh if you can't capture a pawn as The
Rook would hang and if you go back then
just Pawn to H6 and look at this the
white king cannot be activated The Rook
cannot be activated just H7 h8 and it's
game over so that's uh the reason reason
why the queen has to remain on G8 and
param has to wait for the queen to move
and the queen has to wait for param to
move so here Pawn to D4 trying to create
a pass Pawn now Queen to F7 with check
as now that the pawn is on H5 it is
winning so King to D6 now comes Pawn to
E7 attacking The Rook if you move the
Rook then of course you will capture the
Knight so param keeps the Knight but now
comes Queen to F4 with check King
captures an E7 or you go down the board
then a nice Queen F5 check pick up the
Rook here you
know the the lesser of two evils Queen
captures on e4 King to D7 and now Queen
captures on D4 eliminating both of the
pawns and with it all of parham's
counterplay Knight to D6 was played here
ala played Pawn to H6 and he was in this
position unve 43 that param makulu
resigned the game as there is nothing
more to be done here the the Knight is
pinned The Rook has no ideas the queen
already guards the queening square so
just H7 h8 will win the game uh there's
uh nothing to try even like you could
unpin but then still H7 and that's
pretty much it like maybe some C5 action
Queen to E5 will come King to D7 now h8
Queen you don't even have to do this you
could also play it more precisely but uh
even just taking the Rook the position
is
overwhelming uh so after H6 ala takes a
second win in a row and a pretty tough
start for param first draw now a loss
but an exemplary start by Ala by just uh
uh you know showing off his preparation
uh eliminating param without uh you know
of course uh he did have to start
spending time but only when param made
that mistake with Bishop to E6 uh it's
hard to say if we should call that a
mistake but uh you know uh the position
wasn't know one a stronger move has been
played many many times so you know for
for all intents and purposes it's it
should be uh referred to as a mistake uh
so yeah that's the game hope you guys
enjoyed it very nicely done by Resa
will'll see if he will be able to keep
going this this strong for the entire
tournament I would like to thank Welsh
fan Mark Henley Brandon Michael mes
Frank banner and the best content maker
for a contribution to my channel thank
you a lot I really appreciate it as
usual you can check two of my previous
videos here thank you for watching and I
will see you soon continuing to check up
on your wonderful suggestions and
whatever else happens in the Chess World
thank you all I will see you soon and
have an excellent rest of your day